il est implacable
et il est intransigeant son engagement
est juste à cent cinquante pour cent
il travaille d'une manière qui est presque hypnotique
il est comme une grenade à
main  pour les
hommes morts, c'était comme une suite naturelle,
il y avait les ingrédients que
je cherchais et travailler dans
le cinéma américain, l'action VIN et l'
histoire que vous n'avez jamais vues auparavant,
j'adore travailler avec eux parce que nous avons une
relation très honnête, nous le savons  que nous
partageons la même vision ceci pour moi je veux que
vous le tuiez et nous savons que nous
travaillons pour faire quelque chose qui se
démarque ce qui était vraiment attrayant pour moi, c'est
de me connaître en tant qu'actrice dans un
rôle si éloigné de  ce peu
Salander que vous pourriez peut-être penser que je
n'ai jamais pensé à un événement que j'avais vu aller
avec l'intention de la piste - j'ai juste appris aux
talons à faire à peu près tout ce qu'il a tourné
la main en
tant qu'acteur le seul  Ce que vous voulez
avoir avec votre réalisateur, c'est le sentiment de
confiance et je fais confiance à Neal qu'il ne quittera
jamais la scène vraiment
étroite et à moins qu'il ne soit complètement heureux,
il se tient là dans le volcan que nous passons,
ils ont été descendus a un  une énorme quantité
de rebondissements
où vous pensez que vous savez quelque chose et que
quelque chose d'autre se produit vous voulez
vous sauver
Neal a un œil pour l'imagination
vous savez dans l'esprit créatif il n'y a
rien dans ce film qui ne soit pas né de
Niels Arden Oplev